there was a stage production of a play
by Peter quilter called end of the
rainbow produced in 2005 I believe what
are your recollections of seeing it and
what struck you about it and made you
think this is a film well I just thought
I didn't know anything about this story
I just thought what a remarkable story
and thought well I'll option it and then
the next day it was on the front cover
of Arts and Leisure New York Times I
think LA Times LA Times and I thought
well that's that then somebody else has
got it Scott Rudin's got it but I knew
the producer of the play and I thought
well I'll hang on in there and we got it
and it was just it was just you know
there was something remarkable about it
that you could have this huge star
having been in London for this period of
time and having died in London and I
thought well we should do something with
this so Rosalyn Wilder I tracked down
the real Rosalyn Wilder who used in the
film and she opened the gates for a she
introduced us to people have never
spoken about Judy Garland ever so a
dresser who lived in South Africa who
you know very tentatively spoke to me
and said I haven't spoken about Judy for
40 years we spoke to people that were
members of the band we spoke to dancers
and so we gradually kind of this story
emerge that was much more detailed and a
kind of the three hander version of the
play that I hope has made it more you
know real and genuine and giving it a
fabric that it didn't have before but we
were you know he was thrilling Rupert
this film I really feel like allowed you
to combine you know your different
talents of theatre and film and bring a
lot of your theater type experience to
bear for the film was that part of the
appeal for you yeah I guess maybe it's
somewhat of a life thing I felt that I'd
spent 20 years in rehearsal rooms very
close to extraordinary performers and
singers and there's something about
being in a room where you're as close as
we are now which is you never get on the
stage because there's a natural distance
and I felt like kind of witnessing the
extraordinary pressures the performers
go through this sort of transcendent
glory that they can find kind of in the
discovery of their talent particularly
around music and singing and opera and
musical theater that kind of thing I
felt like it would be wonderful if we
could try and obviously garland you know
had that in spades if we could try and
capture what it meant to perform and and
and and sing and the costs of that and
also the the calling of that anyway as
well aside from all the extraordinary
details of her life Renee you've
obviously sung in a film before Chicago
and got an Oscar nomination for it but
when approached with this yes when
approached with this idea when you first
heard about the idea of playing Judy if
one side of the spectrum is I'm in and
the other side of the spectrum is nope
too scary where did you fall at the
beginning the thoughts going between the
two kept me up at night for quite some
time and then there was this shift in
perspective there was no conversation
about the official beginning of the
process there was just an invitation to
come and have a little chat
and so the fellows invited me to London
to just talk about it we'll just talk
about why you know the motivation for
making the film why to tell this story
at this you know about this chapter in
her life try some makeup looks let's try
this wig and then they said and we'll
try some songs and we'll book some time
at Abbey Road and you'll just come and
you'll practice some songs at Abbey Road
and I said let me just put that in my
calendar I'll be right there one thing I
didn't know until yesterday morning was
that you did part of your process and in
learning the voice and getting
comfortable with the voice in your car
often times on the 405 freeway so if if
one of us were to have been driving past
you on the 405 at the exact moment that
you were figuring this character out
what would we have seen
you would have probably called EMS
thinking that the lady next to you is
having a seizure I'm sure of it there
was a lot of contortion there was a lot
of contorting the torso to get the sound
out initially it yeah that or else you
might have just thought wow she's she's
really having fun in there isn't she
David when you think back to putting
this whole production together what was
the biggest challenge as far as finding
the perfect location for something the
one the one that was most important was
the talk of the town so it was the
Hackney Empire that we chose in the end
and we went to see near derelict
theatres in Stratham in with roofs
falling in and Roop it was going yeah we
can rebuild it but what was important
was to find and this is sort of slightly
crossover to you as well but we needed
to find a summer with a thrust stage you
know with which was what the talk of the
town had and it had this black inky
stage and we needed that to be to be
part of it and again coming back to
Rosalind Wilder Rosslyn was the one that
kind of gave us all these pictures from
way back when I had all these snapshots
so she was quite useful in that regard
so we knew what the fine feathers who
the dancers knew exactly what they
looked like and how they dressed and we
knew exactly what the stage would look
like I don't know if you want to say
anything on yeah that particular thrust
stage architectural is certainly in
London is quite hard to find because
it's about the relationship between the
circle and the stage and most proscenium
Victorian theatres have a closer circle
so you couldn't build out a thrust stage
the Hackney Empire which is restored by
Big Lottery grant about 15 years ago is
a lyric house it's four operator and I
guess opera performance is in the late
19th century and it allowed us to build
out further but even then there was a
lot of logistical problems about finding
it that it was gonna be free for the
amount of time we had we had this very
narrow window six days to I think with
three days to fit up and then six days
to shoot and get out and it was pretty
crazy I know it's important to you that
people understand that this was yes it's
your performance but there were a lot of
people at play to help you create what
we saw who were the people who you
remember as being the most integral
well these guys were there for the whole
thing and and it did it felt like a
fluid sort of a series of experiments we
just started trying things with that
visit in London and then we just
continued on from there we worked with
Jeremy Woodhouse and Rob crafter who was
his assistant who did fantastic makeup I
mean just fantastic every day you know
the the glam was period and the
prosthetics were I think pretty hard to
find hard to see and it was just a big
you know a big process and they just a
great job trying everything we just
tried we first put it all on and then
took it all off and I would have kept it
all on if I could have more to hide
behind but and then we you know the
composer Matt Dinkley was there working
when the music every day and and then
Andrew the piano player warming me up
and he was like cheering yes you can and
let's see who else was I mean there's
some journey to meme who made these
beautiful costumes which are just out of
this world
I mean inspired by Judy's dress in the
days and she used antique sequins from
France from the period to make these
dresses as authentically as she could
and and then she fit them to my assumed
posture so that they wouldn't zip up if
I wasn't standing like I was opposed to
yes so I mean all of these you know is
true to be disciplined by antique
sequins and just this way just to throw
in since we've done the list Cave Quinn
who did the production design and just
you know who did that an amazing job and
like you know we're working it's not a
50 million dollar budget you know so
she's you know she's trying to
accommodate everything that Rupert's
constantly demanding every day and doing
an amazing job I mean it's just it looks
fantastic
so Renee when you think about everything
that went into perfecting Judy's
performance
there's the singing there's the dancing
and the movement there and there's the
unique facial expressions which you
capture so beautifully when you think
about all those three things
was there one aspect of it that was
particularly
to feel like you had it mastered about
perfecting and mastering any night I'm
feeling good about it I feel like gosh
it's so interesting when I think back on
this I don't think about it in the
traditional sense of making a film
because it didn't feel like the same
kind of process again it felt like we
were trying things together you know and
we were all digging around to see if
like Rupert called it mining for
treasure we were mining for these little
bits that seemed essential to collect in
order to conjure her essence in some way
and it she's felt like she was
everywhere her photographs and the sound
of her voice and interviews and her
music and and you know the stories going
around and the things that somebody had
discovered the night before that they
bring that day so it felt like I don't
know it was it was almost palpable in
every room that we were working in this
essence of this extraordinary person and
the legacy of her work was very much
alive it sort of just started just to
soak in for everybody and in terms of
difficulty it was such a joy that I
can't look at it like that it just felt
like spoiled rotten you know what a
wonderful professional obligation to
have you know to go down the Judy rabbit
hole and just you know feast on that
every day but some things took more time
but we had time so in the beginning that
the year before we had that time so it's
great to be here with all of you thanks
to all of you for sticking around